This is 99% infecible. I'm Roman Mars. There are a few rules everyone should abide by to have a good life. Always carry a book to read. Never get involved in a land war in Asia. And always, always make friends with people who work in museums. Because there's the museum that everyone else gets to see. The exhibits, the diaramas. I love them all, don't get me wrong. But behind the scenes, there's a whole cabinet of wonder that only a few people get to see. And if you play your cards right, you can get an invitation to the real deal, the museum's
这里是《99%无形》，我是罗曼·马斯。为了过上好生活，每个人都应该遵守几条准则。随身带一本书读。永远不要卷入亚洲的地面战争。而且一定要，一定要和在博物馆工作的人交朋友。因为博物馆里有其他人看不到的一面。那些展品、立体模型，我都很喜欢，别误会。但在幕后，有一个只有少数人能看到的奇妙陈列室。如果你运气好，就能得到邀请，去看看真正的幕后，也就是博物馆的
museum, full of archives, and things neatly lined up in drawers with handwritten tags. A behind the scenes tour of a museum is the greatest way to spend an afternoon. Bar none. This is why I really enjoyed the podcast, Side Door, produced by the Smithsonian Institute in DC and hosted by Lizzy Peabody. They feature stories from the more than 154 million treasures
博物馆，那里堆满了档案，东西整齐地排列在贴着手写标签的抽屉里。博物馆的幕后参观是度过下午时光的最佳方式，没有之一。这就是为什么我非常喜欢由华盛顿特区的史密森尼学会制作、莉齐·皮博迪主持的播客《侧门》。他们讲述了史密森尼档案馆中超过1.54亿件珍宝的故事，
in the Smithsonian archives about art, science, and history. This is my favorite episode of theirs. It's a story of a video game. People call it the worst video game of all time. Based off one of the most popular movies of all time, you're going to love it. I'll let Lizzie Peabody and Sidedoor take it from here. I'm part of a crowd of some four or five hundred people waiting to get into a dump. This is Howard Scott-Warsha.
涵盖艺术、科学和历史。这是我最喜欢他们的一集。这是一个关于电子游戏的故事。人们称它为史上最烂的电子游戏。它改编自史上最受欢迎的电影之一，你一定会喜欢的。接下来就交给莉齐·皮博迪和《侧门》吧。我正身处四五百人的拥挤人群中，等着进入一个垃圾场。这位是霍华德·斯科特·沃肖。
And on April 26, 2014, he was part of an unusual scene, something like a wildly out-of-place tailgate party. People lined up with folding chairs, sun hats, beverages, in the middle of the New Mexico desert. It was a hot day. I mean, it was hot, but there was no dessert. It was just desert. Oh, yeah. How it has a real thing for puns? And the open up, and here we go, and we're all rushing into the dump and there's a lot of excitement, you know, we're on a mission to uncover the truth or not of a very popular urban myth.
2014年4月26日，他身处一个不同寻常的场景中，就像一场极其不合时宜的尾门派对。人们带着折叠椅、遮阳帽、饮料，排队站在新墨西哥州的沙漠中央。那天很热。我是说，天气很热，但没有甜点（dessert），只有沙漠（desert）。哦，对了，霍华德真的很喜欢双关语。然后大门打开，我们出发了，大家都冲进垃圾场，非常兴奋，你知道，我们肩负着揭开一个非常流行的都市传说真相的使命。
The legend goes like this. Once upon a time, in a land called Silicon Valley, an American tech company invented video games that enchanted children and brought billions of dollars flowing through its doors. The company was called Atari. Atari made many good games. Until one day, in 1982, it made a bad one. Oh, really bad one.
传说大致是这样的：很久很久以前，在硅谷这片土地上，一家美国科技公司发明了电子游戏，它让孩子们着迷，并带来了数十亿美元的收入。这家公司叫雅达利。雅达利制作了许多好游戏。直到1982年的某一天，它制作了一款烂游戏。哦，真的非常烂。
A game so bad, it has been called the worst video game of all time. The video game was ET, the extra terrestrial. According to the myth, it was so bad it put Atari out of business. And to hide its shame, Atari buried the unsolved game cartridges in the middle of the desert, where they would never never ever be found. Did you believe that the myth was true? Did you believe that there were games buried in the desert? I never believed it. Why would a company that strapped financially and is really failing and having a lot of trouble staying afloat? Why would they spend extra money to go into the desert and
一款烂到被称为史上最差电子游戏的游戏。这款游戏就是《E.T.外星人》。根据传说，它烂到让雅达利公司倒闭了。为了掩盖耻辱，雅达利把这些卖不出去的游戏卡带埋在了沙漠中央，永远永远都不会被发现。你相信这个传说是真的吗？你相信沙漠里真的埋着游戏吗？我从来不信。一家财务拮据、濒临破产、难以维持经营的公司，为什么要花额外的钱去沙漠里
bury something that supposedly is so worthless, they want to throw it away. That doesn't make any sense at all, right? I mean, that's just nonsense. So Howard was a skeptic, but others in the crowd. I think they believed it, and they were there because they wanted to see it. They wanted to see it come up out of the ground. So there was a ground swell of excitement, you might say.
埋掉一些据说是毫无价值、他们想扔掉的东西呢？这根本说不通，对吧？我是说，这简直是胡说八道。所以霍华德是个怀疑论者，但人群中的其他人，我想他们相信，他们来到这里就是为了亲眼见证。他们想看到它从地底下被挖出来。所以可以说，当时有一种巨大的兴奋浪潮。
So Howard and the rest of the expectant crowd gather around the dump, which is now a dig site. Hundreds of video gamers are there, wearing all their favorite ET gear, their reporters, and even a documentary film crew. The dig begins. There's these huge machines that are super loud. And, they have these giant claws and all these, you know, the X-Govina equipment and super
于是霍华德和其余充满期待的人群聚集在垃圾场周围，这里现在是一个挖掘现场。数百名电子游戏玩家在那里，穿着他们最喜欢的《E.T.》装备，还有记者，甚至还有纪录片摄制组。挖掘开始了。有巨大的机器，声音超级大。它们有巨大的爪子，还有所有那些，你知道的，挖掘设备和超级
drills and just this giant stuff and there's loud machinery, there's all these piles of dirt that have been brought up, of garbage in them and detritus, because it was a dump that has, you know, decades of dump. After six hours of digging, through three decades worth of trash. Outcomes an ET cartridge, a kind of crushed, very damaged ET cartridge. In the end, the excavation team unearthed a total of 1,178 Atari game cartridges.
钻头，还有这些巨大的东西，机器轰鸣，到处都是挖出来的土堆，里面混杂着垃圾和碎屑，因为这是一个有几十年历史的垃圾场。挖掘六小时后，穿过三十年的垃圾，一个《E.T.》卡带出现了，一种被压碎、严重损坏的《E.T.》卡带。最终，挖掘团队总共挖出了1178个雅达利游戏卡带。
Enough to confirm that Atari had actually buried its games in a giant desert pit. So, this time on SideDora, we explore just how those games wound up in the desert. And why popular history blames a tiny pixelated alien for bringing down one of the most influential video game companies of all time. Long ago, before there was PlayStation or Xbox or even Nintendo, there was Atari. It is undoubtedly part of kind of American cultural landscape. If you grew up in the 1980s, you would recognize that symbol immediately. I'm of that generation myself.
足以证实雅达利确实把它的游戏埋在了一个巨大的沙漠坑里。所以，这一期的《侧门》，我们来探讨这些游戏是如何流落到沙漠里的。以及为什么流行历史将一家最具影响力的电子游戏公司之一的倒闭归咎于一个像素化的小外星人。很久以前，在PlayStation、Xbox甚至任天堂出现之前，就有雅达利。它无疑是美国文化景观的一部分。如果你是在20世纪80年代长大的，你会立刻认出那个标志。我自己就是那一代人。
This is Arthur Demrich. He's the director of the Lemelson Center for the Study of Invention and Innovation in the Smithsonian's National Museum of American History. He explained that long ago, there was really only one kind of video game, Arcade Games. To play them, you had to put on pants, leave your house, and go to a shopping mall, bowling alley, or bar. And in the late 1970s, Atari was the first company to create a smash hit arcade game called Pong. They realized pretty quickly that they were on to something. There's amazing stories in the early days of the restaurant and bar owners calling them up and
这位是亚瑟·德姆里奇。他是史密森尼国家美国历史博物馆莱梅尔森发明与创新研究中心的主任。他解释说，很久以前，电子游戏其实只有一种，那就是街机游戏。要玩这些游戏，你得穿上裤子，离开家，去购物中心、保龄球馆或酒吧。在20世纪70年代末，雅达利是第一家创造出名为《Pong》的轰动性街机游戏的公司。他们很快意识到自己发现了一个商机。早期有很多令人惊叹的故事，餐馆和酒吧老板打电话给他们，
saying the machine's broken and they go in and it's not broken at all. It's just completely jammed up with quarters. And they suddenly realized, oh my God. They were so popular. Yes. So many people were going out to bars just to play these games. Atari wondered, what if they made a game that people played at home? At this time, most people didn't have personal computers.
说机器坏了，他们过去一看，机器根本没坏。只是被硬币完全卡住了。他们突然意识到，天哪。它们太受欢迎了。是的。很多人去酒吧只是为了玩这些游戏。雅达利心想，如果他们制作一款人们可以在家里玩的游戏会怎样？当时，大多数人还没有个人电脑。
Television was king. And Atari saw an opportunity. So in 1977, attention shoppers, the new Atari cartridge came in. The Atari appears with a game set that any kid can use and it really transforms the home playing video game market. So what did you need to have at home in order to play an Atari game? A television. That's it. That's right. All of a sudden TV, which had always been passive entertainment, became interactive. That's pretty cool. Yeah, it's very cool. And no one had seen it before. The first sort of demos of video games to play at home, people were utterly confused by
电视是王道。雅达利看到了机会。于是在1977年，顾客们请注意，新的雅达利卡带问世了。雅达利带着任何孩子都能使用的游戏机出现了，它真正改变了家庭电子游戏市场。那么，在家里玩雅达利游戏需要什么？一台电视。就是这样。没错。突然间，一直作为被动娱乐的电视变成了互动式的。那太酷了。是的，非常酷。而且以前没人见过。第一批在家里玩的电子游戏演示，人们完全被搞糊涂了，
what it was. Well, adults may have been confused, but kids got it immediately. Because for such cutting-edge technology, Atari was easy to use. There was a simple console that plugged into your TV, and it was controlled by a joystick with a single red button. On this foundation, Atari built entire digital worlds on screen. And for $199 plus $20 per game cartridge, you could have those worlds in your own home.
不知道那是什么。好吧，成年人可能感到困惑，但孩子们立刻就明白了。因为对于如此尖端的技术，雅达利使用起来非常简单。有一个简单的控制台插在电视上，由一个带有一个红色按钮的操纵杆控制。在这个基础上，雅达利在屏幕上构建了整个数字世界。只需199美元加上每个游戏卡带20美元，你就可以在自己家里拥有这些世界。
The new video computer system by Atari. More games, more fun. Atari took off. They brought the excitement of the arcade into the suburban living room. And to do it, they hired the world's best programmers. These guys were geniuses at figuring out how to make interesting games and make them fun.
雅达利推出的全新视频计算机系统。更多游戏，更多乐趣。雅达利腾飞了。他们把街机的兴奋感带进了郊区的客厅。为了做到这一点，他们聘请了世界上最优秀的程序员。这些家伙是天才，他们知道如何制作有趣的游戏并让它们变得好玩。
Many of these genius programmers were young men right out of college, and one of them was Howard Scott Worshaw, our friend from the desert. And he was pretty good at his job. I was pretty good at my job. My first game that I did for Atari was Yars Revenge. That was the first game I think that ever actually had a pause mode. Whoa.
这些天才程序员中许多是刚从大学毕业的年轻人，其中一位就是我们在沙漠里的朋友，霍华德·斯科特·沃肖。他在工作中表现非常出色。我在工作中表现得很好。我为雅达利做的第一个游戏是《Yars Revenge》。我想那是第一个真正有暂停模式的游戏。哇。
It was the first full screen explosion. It was a more elaborate use of sound than people had seen before. There was an incredible amount of color. I wanted a frenetic action game that demanded attention and that would grab someone right by their cognitive elements and not release them. That's what I was trying to do with Yars Revenge. Wow. Yars Revenge transformed Howard into what fans called a Game God. Even though Atari didn't credit its programmers publicly, fans would sluth out the minds behind
那是第一个全屏爆炸的游戏。它对声音的使用比人们以前见过的更复杂。色彩极其丰富。我想要一款疯狂的动作游戏，它能吸引注意力，能抓住玩家的认知元素而不放手。这就是我制作《Yars Revenge》时想要达到的效果。哇。《Yars Revenge》让霍华德变成了粉丝口中的“游戏之神”。尽管雅达利没有公开给程序员署名，但粉丝们还是会挖掘出他们最喜欢的游戏背后的天才。
their favorite games. The growing community of American gamers was that passionate. It was the golden age of Atari. By 1980, Atari was the fastest growing company in the history of the United States, commanding 75% of the home video game market and bringing in more than $2 billion a year. They produced their own games, but they also licensed their name to outside game developers, slapping the Atari label on all kinds of third-party games. No other company could keep up. In 1981, Atari conquered Hollywood. Hollywood. Howard spent eight months working on Raiders of the Lost Ark, the video game, strutting
美国游戏玩家群体日益壮大，充满热情。那是雅达利的黄金时代。到1980年，雅达利是美国历史上增长最快的公司，占据了75%的家用电子游戏市场，每年带来超过20亿美元的收入。他们制作自己的游戏，但也授权给外部游戏开发商，在各种第三方游戏上贴上雅达利的标签。没有其他公司能跟上。1981年，雅达利征服了好莱坞。好莱坞。霍华德花了八个月时间制作《夺宝奇兵》电子游戏，戴着软呢帽，挥舞着鞭子在雅达利总部走来走去，
around Atari HQ with a Fedora and a Whip, the Daniel Day Lewis of Game Goddry. The game sold well, so when Steven Spielberg made another blockbuster, ET, the extra terrestrial, in the summer of 1982, it was a no-brainer. Of course, Atari would make ET the video game. Here's how Howard remembers it. We're hanging out in my office, and then a call came in. And it was the CEO of Atari, who actually never calls me. He's basically my boss's boss, bosses, bosses, boss. The CEO of Atari calls 25-year-old Howard and says,
简直是游戏神界的丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯。这款游戏卖得很好，所以当史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格在1982年夏天制作另一部大片《E.T.外星人》时，这简直是理所当然的事。雅达利当然会制作《E.T.》电子游戏。霍华德是这样回忆的：我们当时在我的办公室里闲逛，然后接到了一个电话。是雅达利CEO打来的，他其实从不给我打电话。他基本上是我老板的老板的老板的老板的老板。雅达利CEO给25岁的霍华德打电话说，
we want you to make ET the video game, and we need it done by September 1st. Now, this is July 27th, so at least five weeks and a half day to do the game. five weeks and a half day to do the game. Five weeks and a half day. To give you a sense of how insane this is, video games at the time took six to eight months to create. And this guy is saying,
我们想让你制作《E.T.》电子游戏，我们需要在9月1日前完成。现在是7月27日，所以只有五个星期零半天的时间来制作这款游戏。五个星期零半天来制作这款游戏。五个星期零半天。为了让你了解这有多疯狂，当时制作电子游戏需要六到八个月。而这家伙却说，
Howard, we need you to create a game for the highest-grossing blockbuster film of the year in just 20% of the time it usually takes. You can do that, right? And I said to him, absolutely I can. Did it ever occur to you that it might not be possible? Was there a part of you that acknowledged that this might be impossible?
霍华德，我们需要你在通常所需时间的20%内，为年度票房最高的大片制作一款游戏。你能做到，对吧？我对他说，我绝对能做到。你有没有想过这可能是不可能的？有没有一部分的你承认这可能是不可能的？
To be perfectly honest, I don't think it ever occurred to me that it couldn't be done. So how would it go to work? And he worked. And he worked. I was brutal. I was grueling. Like how the development system moved into my home.
老实说，我不认为我曾经想过这事做不到。所以霍华德去工作了。他工作，他工作。太残酷了。太折磨人了。就像开发系统搬进了我的家里。
So that no matter where I was, I was no more than two minutes away at any point in time from actually sitting down and doing something on the game. And even when he wasn't sitting down, eating, driving, showering, he was working in his head. And when he was asleep, still working. I thought, you know what I need to do is turn sleep into an asset. I would work until I ran into a problem.
这样无论我在哪里，我离坐下来做游戏的时间都不会超过两分钟。即使他不坐着的时候，吃饭、开车、洗澡，他脑子里也在工作。睡觉时，还在工作。我想，你知道我需要做什么，就是把睡眠变成一种资产。我会一直工作到遇到问题。
And then I would go to sleep. And I would think, okay, maybe if I can just sleep and come up with something, if I can literally dream up a solution, I thought that would be kind of cool. And there were some times where that happened. So Howard, all of this sounds crazy. Why did they even ask you to do this?
然后我就去睡觉。我会想，好吧，也许如果我能睡一觉并想出点什么，如果我能真的梦到一个解决方案，我觉得那会很酷。确实有几次发生了这种情况。所以霍华德，这一切听起来很疯狂。他们为什么要让你做这件事？
It's a really good question, right? Why would you put someone through something like this? Right. And well, if you were to ask the executives, they would say, huh? So they didn't even know what they were asking of you. No, they had no concept. The management of Atari was completely disconnected
这是一个很好的问题，对吧？为什么要让一个人经历这种事？对。嗯，如果你去问高管们，他们会说，啊？所以他们甚至不知道他们在要求你做什么。不，他们根本没有概念。雅达利的管理层与生产完全脱节。
from production. According to management, ET the video game needed to be in stores by Christmas, or they'd lose millions of dollars in potential holiday revenue. But Atari and Spielberg had taken so long nailing down a licensing agreement that by the time they finally did get pen to paper, there was almost no time left to make the game. That never occurred to anyone. This was a case of people believing they could do nothing wrong and myself included.
根据管理层的说法，《E.T.》电子游戏必须在圣诞节前上架，否则他们会损失数百万美元的潜在假日收入。但雅达利和斯皮尔伯格在敲定授权协议上花了太长时间，以至于当他们最终签字时，几乎没有时间制作游戏了。这从来没在任何人脑子里出现过。这是一个人们认为自己不会犯错的案例，包括我自己。
Everybody at Atari thought, you know, we're on top, no one can touch us, we can do anything. And honestly, it seemed like they could. Against all odds, Howard delivered E.T. the video game in just five weeks. I was a hero. There was a huge company meeting at which, you know, they called me up on stage. He said, hey, how it came through. Oh, yeah. Steven Spielberg himself called Howard a quote, certifiable genius. And by Christmas time, five million cartridges of the much anticipated ET the video game stocked the shelves of stores nationwide.
雅达利的每个人都认为，你知道，我们处于顶峰，没人能触碰我们，我们可以做任何事。老实说，看起来他们确实能做到。克服重重困难，霍华德在短短五周内交付了《E.T.》电子游戏。我是英雄。公司开了一个大型会议，他们把我叫上台。他说，嘿，霍华德成功了。哦，是的。史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格本人称霍华德为“认证天才”。到圣诞节时，备受期待的《E.T.》电子游戏有500万份卡带摆满了全国各地的商店货架。
So mission accomplished, right? Well, not exactly. You're listening to Side Door, on 99% of visible, produced by the Smithsonian Institute with PRX, more after this. From Side Door, here again, is Lizzy Peabody. Here's where we are. It's December 1982. Steven Spielberg's soon-to-be classic movie, ET, The Extra Terrestrial, is out in theaters.
所以任务完成了，对吧？嗯，不完全是。你正在收听的是《99%无形》中的《侧门》，由史密森尼学会与PRX联合制作，稍后继续。欢迎回到《侧门》，我是莉齐·皮博迪。现在的情况是：1982年12月。史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格即将成为经典的电影《E.T.外星人》正在影院上映。
In Atari, the American video game Titan just released the thing every kid was waiting for. ET, the video game. The video game that lets you help ET get home. Just in time for Christmas. Howard Scott Worshaw, Atari's star programmer, created the game in only five weeks. Spielberg is happy. Atari leadership is happy. Howard is happy.
而美国电子游戏巨头雅达利刚刚发布了每个孩子都在等待的东西：《E.T.》电子游戏。这款让你帮助E.T.回家的游戏。正好赶上圣诞节。雅达利的明星程序员霍华德·斯科特·沃肖仅用五周就制作了这款游戏。斯皮尔伯格很高兴。雅达利领导层很高兴。霍华德很高兴。
Guess who is not happy? Eight-year-old Jason, Christmas morning, thoroughly disappointed. This is a man that Sidor does not like to disappoint. My name is Jason Arfano, I'm the executive producer of Scydor, aka your boss. Thanks for the reminder. Justin, can I please have like a latte or something? Perhaps more Roman therapy? We brought Jason into the studio because he has some personal history with ET.
猜猜谁不高兴？8岁的杰森，圣诞节早晨，彻底失望了。这是一个《侧门》不想让其失望的人。我叫杰森·阿法诺，我是《侧门》的执行制片人，也就是你的老板。谢谢提醒。贾斯汀，我能来杯拿铁什么的吗？也许再来点罗曼疗法？我们把杰森请进演播室，因为他和《E.T.》有一些个人渊源。
When ET, the movie came out, I was 8 and ET was everything. I mean, there were stuffed animals for ET. I had a ton of them. You know, I learned how to draw ET. That was a big deal. So ET was a huge part of the summer of 1982. Jason was also into Atari. He played every day after school and when he started seeing ads for ET the video game, he had really high hopes. Oh my God, I can play the movie. I was gonna ride my bike in the game
当《E.T.》电影上映时，我8岁，E.T.就是一切。我是说，有E.T.的毛绒玩具。我有一大堆。你知道，我学会了画E.T.。那是一件大事。所以E.T.是1982年夏天非常重要的一部分。杰森也喜欢雅达利。他每天放学后都玩，当他开始看到《E.T.》电子游戏的广告时，他抱有很高的期望。天哪，我可以玩这部电影了。我可以在游戏里骑自行车，
and maybe fly through the air. You know, maybe I can- On Christmas morning, there it was under the tree. ET the video game. Right up to my room, opened up the box, pulled the game out, stuck it into the Atari, turned it on. There's ET on that first screen. It's super exciting.
也许可以在空中飞。你知道，也许我可以——圣诞节早晨，它就在树下。《E.T.》电子游戏。我跑到房间里，打开盒子，拿出游戏，插进雅达利，打开电源。E.T.出现在第一个屏幕上。超级令人兴奋。
It plays a little song that's you know, the song that's kind of like the ET song but not quite and started playing the game. And that's when I realized that something was wrong. The game was nothing like the movie. The objective of the game is for ET to collect pieces of a phone so that he can, of course, phone home. ET, phone home.
它播放了一首小曲子，你知道，那首歌有点像E.T.的主题曲，但又不太像，然后开始玩游戏。就在那时，我意识到出问题了。游戏和电影一点也不像。游戏的目标是让E.T.收集电话碎片，这样他当然可以给家里打电话。E.T.给家里打电话。
ET, phone home. I never finished the game. It was so incredibly hard and confusing. It doesn't sound that hard. And Jason is older and wiser now, so we decided to play it. Okay, let's do it. Oh no. I'm nervous, I'm super nervous.
E.T.给家里打电话。我从来没通关过。它太难了，太让人困惑了。听起来没那么难。杰森现在年纪大了，也更聪明了，所以我们决定玩一下。好吧，开始吧。哦，不。我很紧张，我超级紧张。
Okay, are you ready? All right, there you go. All right, ET is landing in his tiny little spaceship and now he's in this this what looks like a forest. It didn't go so well. Oh my god. Alright, there is a government man coming after me and he's like, what is he doing? He's just sort of bumping into me.
好了，准备好了吗？好了，开始吧。好了，E.T.正在降落在他的小飞船里，现在他在这个看起来像森林的地方。进行得不太顺利。天哪。好了，有一个政府人员在追我，他这是在干什么？他只是撞到了我。
Nothing happens. In the game, it's hard to figure out where you're supposed to be going. And as you try to navigate the game world, you keep falling into these pits that are everywhere. Alright, I'm in a pit. This is the worst part of the game. And there are random characters trying to get you. And now who's that guy? And you might be thinking, hey, what would Howard say about you talking smack about his game? But he agrees.
什么也没发生。在游戏里，很难弄清楚你应该去哪里。当你试图在游戏世界中导航时，你会不断掉进到处都是的坑里。好了，我掉进坑里了。这是游戏最糟糕的部分。还有随机的角色试图抓住你。现在那个人是谁？你可能会想，嘿，霍华德听到你吐槽他的游戏会怎么说？但他同意。
ET commits the ultimate video game sin to disorient the user. And you have to understand the difference between frustration and disorientation, right? Frustration in a video game is essential, right? A video game must frustrate a user, but you should never disorient them. Howard says that frustration ultimately creates satisfaction. It's a huge motivator in a good game, to get better, faster, stronger. Disorientation on the other hand is just... I'm in a pit.
《E.T.》犯了电子游戏的终极罪行：让用户迷失方向。你必须理解挫败感和迷失方向之间的区别，对吧？电子游戏中的挫败感是必不可少的，对吧？电子游戏必须让用户感到挫败，但绝不应该让他们迷失方向。霍华德说，挫败感最终会创造满足感。在好游戏中，它是让人变得更好、更快、更强的巨大动力。另一方面，迷失方向只是……我掉进坑里了。
I fell in another pit. Terrible. But back in the winter of 1982, Howard thought everything was peachy, because ET, the extra terrible game, was selling pretty well. But as soon as the young Jason or Fanon's of the world started playing it, word got out, and sales virtually stopped, leaving unsolved ET games clogging the shelves of stores. And by early 1983, Howard started to hear rumblings. People from other parts of the company, you know, suits as we would come walking by and engineering
我又掉进另一个坑里了。太糟糕了。但在1982年的冬天，霍华德认为一切都很美好，因为《E.T.》这款“极其糟糕”的游戏卖得相当不错。但当像年轻的杰森·阿法诺这样的人开始玩它时，消息传开了，销量几乎停止了，导致卖不出去的《E.T.》游戏堆满了商店货架。到1983年初，霍华德开始听到传言。公司其他部门的人，你知道，我们称之为“西装男”的人，会走过工程部，
some time, and people would look at me and they'd go, you know Howard, you really came through for us. We don't blame you. And I'm thinking, that's nice. You know what are you talking about? I didn't know what was happening out there. What was happening out there? Millions of unsold games coming back to Atari. Games they'd banked on selling. Atari sold them to a distributor who placed them in stores but the distributor had the full right of return. Oh so they could return their stock to Atari. Right so all the ones that they didn't sell the stores gave back to the distributor and the distributor then returns to Atari as unsold product. Okay. And so they went belly up. Wow.
有时，人们会看着我说，你知道霍华德，你真的为我们做到了。我们不怪你。我在想，那很好。你知道你在说什么吗？我不知道外面发生了什么。外面发生了什么？数百万未售出的游戏退回给雅达利。他们指望靠这些游戏赚钱。雅达利把它们卖给了一个分销商，分销商把它们放在商店里，但分销商有完全的退货权。哦，所以他们可以把库存退给雅达利。没错，所以所有没卖出去的，商店退给分销商，分销商再作为未售出产品退给雅达利。好吧。于是他们破产了。哇。
E.T. was a big liability, but its very creation spoke to an even bigger problem for Atari. The company had made a habit of prioritizing money over quality. Remember how in an attempt to get more games on the market, Atari let outside companies make them? Well a lot of those third party games were bad too. And so Atari's name gets associated with some really bad games that nobody really likes and that aren't selling well. What's more, by 1983 programmers had reached the Atari console's limits for memory and graphics. All the games kind of started to look the same.
《E.T.》是一个巨大的负担，但它的诞生反映了雅达利更大的问题。公司已经习惯了把金钱置于质量之上。还记得为了让市场上出现更多游戏，雅达利让外部公司制作游戏吗？嗯，那些第三方游戏里有很多也很烂。所以雅达利的名字和一些没人喜欢、销量也不好的烂游戏联系在了一起。更重要的是，到1983年，程序员已经达到了雅达利控制台在内存和图形方面的极限。所有的游戏开始看起来都一样了。
And gamers got bored. People stopped buying consoles. Atari was in big trouble. So when Atari went down 1983 into 1984, the entire video game industry tanks in the United States. But it basically wiped out sales of home game sets. The history books call it the video game crash of 1983. American video game sales dropped by over 90%
玩家们感到厌烦。人们停止购买控制台。雅达利陷入了大麻烦。所以当雅达利在1983年到1984年倒下时，整个电子游戏产业在美国崩溃了。它基本上抹杀了家用游戏机的销量。历史书称之为1983年的电子游戏大崩溃。美国电子游戏销量下降了超过90%
from 1982 to 1986. No new game systems were introduced and hardly any new games were created at all until the late 80s. That's when Japanese companies Nintendo and Sega brought their consoles and their famous characters to the United States. But it would be nearly two decades before another American-made console would return to the market in any significant way, with Microsoft's Xbox in 2001.
从1982年到1986年。没有新的游戏系统推出，直到80年代末几乎没有创造出任何新游戏。那时，日本公司任天堂和世嘉带着他们的控制台和著名角色来到了美国。但直到2001年微软Xbox的出现，美国制造的控制台才时隔近二十年以任何重要方式重返市场。
So there's no question that when you have an economic downturn, you have a catastrophe, a natural disaster, there's an effort to put a face on it, an individual story on it. You have to have a face, right? ET became the face of the fall of the video game industry because it was very identifiable. And I became the butt behind that face. On September 26, 1983, much like the character in the game, ET fell into its own pit in Alamagordo, New Mexico. Not for any symbolic reason, but because dumping laws
所以毫无疑问，当你经历经济衰退、灾难、自然灾害时，人们会试图给它贴上一个面孔，一个个人故事。你必须有一个面孔，对吧？《E.T.》成为了电子游戏产业衰落的面孔，因为它非常容易辨认。而我成了那个面孔背后的“屁股”。1983年9月26日，就像游戏里的角色一样，《E.T.》掉进了它在新墨西哥州阿拉莫戈多的坑里。不是因为任何象征意义，而是因为那里的倾倒法
relaxed there, and Atari needed a cheap way to dispose of its 14 truckloads of unsolved game cartridges. ET the video game was steamrolled, covered in cement, and largely forgotten. Until 2014, when those cartridges were exhumed, and one of them found a home here in Washington DC at the National Museum of American History. So it's kind of crunched, it looks cracked. Like if you tried to play this, it probably wouldn't go well. We have not tried it, obviously for the reason. Right. Smithsonian Museum Specialist Drew Abarge took ET out of the collections to show it to me.
放宽了，雅达利需要一种廉价的方式来处理它的14卡车未售出的游戏卡带。《E.T.》电子游戏被压路机压平，覆盖上水泥，并被大部分人遗忘。直到2014年，这些卡带被挖掘出来，其中一个在华盛顿特区的国家美国历史博物馆找到了归宿。所以它有点被压扁了，看起来有裂纹。就像如果你试图玩这个，可能不会有好结果。我们显然没有尝试过，原因你知道的。史密森尼博物馆专家德鲁·阿巴奇把《E.T.》从藏品中拿出来给我看。
But it still has dust on it, it still has like sort of like white crusty. Yeah. Like is that a rock or what is it, is that just gunk? I think it's just gunk, you know, this was in with tons of other stuff, you know, plastic parts, you know, paper, instruction manual boxes, all this kind of stuff. Drew's role doesn't usually involve collecting objects, but he's a gamer himself. I jumped that I was born with a controller in my hand. But he's a gamer himself. When he heard that a film crew applied for a permit to dig up the fabled Atari Gravesite,
但它上面还有灰尘，还有那种白色的结壳。是的。那是石头还是什么，那是污垢吗？我想那只是污垢，你知道，它和成吨的其他东西混在一起，你知道，塑料零件，纸，说明书盒子，所有这些东西。德鲁的角色通常不涉及收集物品，但他自己也是个玩家。我敢说我出生时手里就拿着手柄。但他自己也是个玩家。当他听说一个摄制组申请了挖掘传说中的雅达利墓地的许可证时，
he wanted to make sure the museum secured a cartridge. Because E.T. the video game tells the story of something bigger than its own dirt-crusted case. It's about the rise and fall of the company that pioneered video gaming in America. And although it's not very old, it hints at the digital revolution that followed. It's a piece of American history. I was just afraid that if I didn't act now, like, probably nobody else would had realized the synonyms of it, so I felt it was like the first time I felt like I had to do
他想确保博物馆能拿到一个卡带。因为《E.T.》电子游戏讲述了一个比它自身布满尘土的盒子更大的故事。它是关于在美国开创电子游戏先河的公司的兴衰。虽然它并不古老，但它暗示了随后的数字革命。它是美国历史的一部分。我只是担心如果我现在不采取行动，可能没人会意识到它的意义，所以我感觉这是我第一次觉得我必须做
something if not it, the opportunity might have been lost. Howard Scott Worshaw left Atari in 1984 and eventually became a therapist. But he recognizes his role in Atari's story. And on that day in the desert, when ET was pulled from the ground. I looked around and I thought, this is awesome. This is so awesome. Because something that I did, you know,
点什么，否则机会可能就失去了。霍华德·斯科特·沃肖在1984年离开雅达利，最终成为了一名治疗师。但他认识到自己在雅达利故事中的角色。在那天沙漠里，当《E.T.》从地里被拉出来时。我环顾四周，心想，这太棒了。这太棒了。因为我做的事情，你知道，
a few thousand lines of code that I had written over 30 years ago is still generating all this excitement in that moment. I felt a tremendous sense of satisfaction in that I had really created something that meant something to a lot of people. And that meant something to me. While Atari never regained video game supremacy, the culture it created endures in the fans who bow down before their game gods, and stand for hours in the desert to see an old piece of plastic dredged from a dump.
我30多年前写的几千行代码，在那个时刻仍然引发了所有这些兴奋。我感到一种巨大的满足感，因为我确实创造了一些对很多人来说意义重大的东西。这对我也意义重大。虽然雅达利从未重获电子游戏霸权，但它创造的文化在那些向游戏之神顶礼膜拜的粉丝中得以延续，他们站在沙漠里几个小时，只为看一眼从垃圾场挖出来的旧塑料片。
A game cartridge now preserved in the Smithsonian's collections. Once worthless, now priceless. The Side Door is hosted by Lizzie Peabody. It's produced by Justin O'Neill, Jason Orphanon, Ellen Rolfes, Caitlin Schaefer, Jess Sadeck, Lara Koch, Ann Kenan, and Sharon Bryant, music by Break Master Syllinder, with support from John Barth, Jason Saldana, and Genevieve Sponsler at PRX, mixing by direct fooda.
一个现在保存在史密森尼藏品中的游戏卡带。曾经一文不值，现在无价之宝。《侧门》由莉齐·皮博迪主持。由贾斯汀·奥尼尔、杰森·阿法诺、艾伦·罗尔夫斯、凯特琳·谢弗、杰西·萨德克、拉拉·科赫、安·基南和莎伦·布莱恩特制作，音乐由Break Master Syllinder创作，PRX的约翰·巴斯、杰森·萨尔达纳和吉纳维芙·斯庞斯勒提供支持，混音由Direct Fooda完成。
This show is produced by the Smithsonian with support from PRX, the public radio exchange. You can find the show at s-i.edu slash side door. This episode of 99% of visible was pulled together by Chris Perubey and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
本节目由史密森尼学会制作，并得到PRX（公共广播交易所）的支持。你可以在si.edu/sidedoor找到本节目。这一集《99%无形》由克里斯·佩鲁比和我罗曼·马斯共同整理。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。
99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm and you can find us at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99%无形》是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm可以找到他们，你也可以在99pi.org找到我们。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。